[Music]
[Music]
to steal their Christmas cookie this is
our enemy
no no we must resist this new fellow
with the skin our brain is teeth are
yellow we will drop the slave from the
roof okay
go team you smile if I'm gonna become
Santa then I need to get into character
it's got your heart until now we'll be
riding in style Oh
[Music]
declaration of town now you can access
layout
[Music]
who is this - in greenish-yellow
max I'm promoting you you will guide my
sleigh tonight
what max
[Music]
Brij
max you know the rules you sleep in your
bed and I sleep in that's did you teach
him puppy eyes fine today was great we
did mean things and we did them in style
max you know the rules you sleep in our
bed and I sleep in oh no no not you too
I don't believe this max did you teach
him puppy eyes find this one time
the presence this is our enemy you will
want to unwrap it and I
[Music]
who's that you must know if you can get
past the present the only obstacle left
is
the cookie look at it in all its red
sugary splendor pick yourselves
disciplined we must resist
beautiful isn't it max this my little
friend is a the rain horn it perfectly
recreates the mating call of the
reindeer the help
oh hey there sorry little goat I was
calling for a roofer what's that
scram cattle strange goat
all this excess and nonsense it was all
about greed about meaningless stuff that
they didn't even need yeah The Grinch
went to work he scooped up the toys he
raced against time he raced against joy
he had a few snags as he made his way
through an angry orange cat and a
sleepwalking who thank you mommy
you know what if you want to apologize
for something apologize for that my eyes
are burning
don't blame me haven't you heard the
mayor wants Christmas to be three times
bigger this year that means three times
the lights three times the eggnog three
times the information needed ha ha
that's a good one oh this is one of your
kidding things finally something you
I don't speak ridiculous scream have a
nice life two five I'll see you later
this may become the next great name in
figure skating
[Music]
beautiful
[Music]
no joke
don't bring me down
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
how much I don't know about the Grinch
okay yes I know I'm could do great where
does the Grinch live Mount crumpit what
are the names of Cindy Lou's brothers I
know they both start with the beat Brad
Bret
no one's pinging Buster and being that's
my kids Nance
how many sizes too small is the Grinch's
heart two times just me Tim easy however
many sizes too small his heart there's a
very strong beating heart to this
there's a reason why he is so lost
that's beautiful
how would the Grinch handle stress whale
sounds come on now immersion therapy by
just throwing himself into the center of
Whoville performing some form of
mashallah a discipline like jiu-jitsu
genius starts with the ABS max junior
Grinch here grits
let's talk about last year's game one
yikes those last year let it go you're
right no turning back the clock now
nothing only time will tell how
[Music]
Matt stop so sizing now let's go in for
a look
watch out Christmas already
look at those greedy little gift
monsters ready
oh hey look it's me
[Music]
[Music]
you owe me one mr. Grinch you as cuddly
as a cactus what's that checkmate again
today we will do mean things and we will
do them in style
[Music]
[Music]
I'm going to see you better Christmas
read this perfectly recreates a mating
call at the reindeer the ho Wow hey
there sorry little goat I was looking
for a rare
[Music]
the grid is loudest snow I've ever heard
in my life
are you doing okay if I could describe
the Grinch's attitude in one word it
would have to be thoroughly nasty awful
grouchy Grinchy
today we will do mean things and we will
do them in style everyone gets a
vicarious thrill out of how the grinch
babes they kind of like enjoy seeing
someone new it's Christmas I could
relate to the Grinch I can see myself as
that character no more fouls no more
trees no more lights just give me a
break
leave mr. grit alone yeah old feisty
rustic come on
positive vibes and cool vibes good vibes
only maybe he needs to go to therapy
that's not gonna happen I would like to
think I'm a ho but I'm probably a Grinch
I can definitely be a Grinch at some
times I've lost capable of getting a bit
Grinch it Christmas you don't have to be
green it helps to be green but he don't
have to be
you're a mean one mr. Tremont who is
this I've always liked you excuse me
you're green and grumpy love talking
trash and you scream a lot we've done
her and you know just how to get under
someone's skin I love that keep it up
I'm about to get under your skin yeah
just don't stop being you you hear me
Joe al Grinch here how is my favorite
internet troll hey come on man spending
all day on social media part of the
process please use my number maybe
you'll snag a date with that certain
someone you're always talking about by a
Grinch
never call me again
a nation
[Applause]
[Music]
your bad banana with her
that
[Music]
today we will do mean things and we will
do them inside
[Music]
[Music]
the grid
[Music]